[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's cameron with
motion science how is everyone doing
today how's everyone doing who's here
today let me know who's here
where are you listening in from where
are you watching from
who is here today on this fine fine day
tuesday january 25th uh today we're
going to talk about uh photoshop
neural neural filters
and how to use them with after effects
to create
the parallax effect
it's a pretty cool effect
it's a way easier way to um this
technique's super easy to to do
compared to the old-school way that i
used to do this technique
so when i saw that neural filters could
do this i was like whoa
immediately like hey we can use this for
displacement mapping and parallax
effects
so that's we're going to talk about
today um but before i get into that
i want to hear from you guys so who's
here today
um
and where are you listening in front
from
uh oh there goes my camera it's freaking
out on me see i don't know why it does
this right ai ai filters
crazy
uh let's see here we've got every time i
look to the right it seems like boop
move over there that's weird
uh we have luke luke is here what's
going on luke
uh i love the countdown graphics so much
is it mirror or i don't know i actually
it's it's stock
uh so i did not build the intro graphic
i have a bunch of them that i want to
actually kind of work through
but uh come on camera what's going on
here
let's actually
try something here
don't know why it's doing this
maybe this will be a little bit better
weird
um so no i did not create it if i had to
guess i would say uh mer mirror i don't
know how you pronounce it right or um
trap code form but it's a trap code
plugin it's got to be
uh abraham what's going on abraham here
we go
acv creation
big fan hey acv creation
black smoke productions what's going on
alessandro
yeah something about parallax effect
yeah you'll enjoy this one
uh
abraham is from lagos nigeria amazing
black smoke
uh okay so we have a few people on here
at least so that's cool thanks for being
here today guys i really appreciate that
uh for those of you who are watching
into the recording of this um always
feel free to leave comments below the
video and let me know
where you're calling in from
so i know who's watching these videos
it's always great to hear feedback and
let people you know hear back from
people and know that you guys are
enjoying these videos so
always feel free to leave a comment even
a question if you have a question leave
it below the video
um hello from india what's going on
egypt
nice
uh for those of you who don't know who i
am if you're brand new here my name is
cameron i've been a motion designer for
20 years
working after effects in cinema 4d and
maya and lightwave
i taught myself design and animation
actually started with
started with animation then taught
myself design
so
i did this all by creating spec work for
myself this is personal work i want to
create it create for myself this helped
me on my first motion design job
i was remote freelancer for 13 years
and i've owned and operated two small
boutique post houses
i had the opportunity to work with a lot
of big agencies and studios across the
world and
clients that
the list goes on and on i've been very
fortunate to work with some of these
clients so
american express disney microsoft mtv
rca sony
on and on and on um okay so before i get
into neural filters today
i want to talk give you two
two housekeeping
things i want to talk about one
let me make sure i can switch this over
here
uh one is i have a five day challenge it
starts next monday january 31st
depending on when you're watching this
um
it's a five-day challenge
starts january 31st
it's a challenge called the realize your
motion graphic career
challenge like i said it is five days
long um it's five days of life uh
teaching and um coaching and uh q and
a's and if you want a career in motion
graphics you need to check this
challenge out but the only way you can
check it out is by signing up with the
link below this which is
motionscience.tv
[Music]
challenge hyphen sign hyphen up
not the not the easiest um
[Music]
url
but um
that's what it is motion science dot tv
backslash challenge hyphen sign hyphen
up
five day challenge
if you're interested in having a motion
graphic career you definitely want to
check this out
uh other thing i want to talk about like
i talk about in every video i also have
a free workshop over at motionscience.tv
workshop where i show you seven secrets
to cinematic motion design
these are seven tips tricks and concepts
behind pro level motion design plus i
give you access to a special offer that
you won't find anywhere else
so please check it out if you haven't
already
done so
okay
so um let's jump over
let me
move a couple things around here
and
let me
pull
up photoshop and let me switch my screen
here
so you guys can see it ah perfect okay
here we go
okay so
we're inside of photoshop here and i'm
showing you photoshop 2021 because
i don't have this filter installed so i
wanted to show you guys how to actually
install this filter before we get going
so it's really easy
i think you have to have 2021 or 2022
photoshop
i don't know that any versions below
that work with this i'm not totally sure
but if you go to filter
and you go down here to neural filters
it's going to go ahead and load them up
over here on the right and these are
some crazy filters i've only played
around with a couple of them but you
should definitely take your time and
just kind of play around with these um
but it's called depth blurts right here
and it says new but there's a little
cloud icon here it says this filter must
be downloaded first you're going to
click that
and you're going to download
this filter
and i don't want to download it to 2021
so i'm going to switch over to 2022
and
same thing filter
neural filters it's going to load them
up
um and you can see i already have it
installed here there's no cloud so all i
have to do to turn this on is to just
load up an image which i have this image
i got from unsplash here
and you can see the the file name up
here arisa hyphen
if you want to go find this on unsplash
so all i have to do is just turn this
little switch on here
and it's going to do its thing down here
it's processing
the image and you're going to see what
happens to this imagery you're going to
see a depth
map
up here on here okay
and it automatically did it and i don't
know if you noticed immediately it
changed the focal depth the focal point
so
originally
this was all pretty much in focus and
now the background is out of focus and
the foreground's in focus
so over here in this window you can see
it says click to edit focal point i can
literally click anywhere so if i click
like back here at the top you're going
to see over here
that this is going to become in focus
and the foreground is going to go out of
focus so i'll click
and it's going to do its processing
and boom there you go so now the
background's in focus the foreground's
out of focus right so it's a pretty cool
like
again it can create depth
depth of field in an image which is
pretty mind-blowing
there's also a couple little
um
let's move these windows out of the way
here
a couple different settings you can play
around with here i'm not gonna play
around with those
my my main thing here is i want to go
down and also you can adjust the blur
strength actually so it's set to 50. so
if i you can see the foreground here if
i turn this up to let's say 100 you're
gonna see that the foreground is going
to
get a lot blurrier which it did right
there so
again you can play around with all these
little settings but um the main thing
we're concerning ourselves with today is
the output depth map only which is over
oh you actually can't see it cause my my
head is in the way
let me move my head out of the way here
sorry about that
okay
all right now you should be able to see
down here
um it says
output depth math depth
map only if i can speak today
i clicked that and you can see boom
we've got this grayscale image here
which is a depth map okay now one thing
that i play around with sometimes is
there's one when you turn this on it
takes all these controls out but it
leaves one option here which you can
click to focus subject and you're going
to see some different things happen here
in kind of the middle ground
it just kind of depends on the image if
this works or not for this particular
image
it's creating some kind of weird
artifacts here that aren't going to work
for what i want to do so i'm going to
turn it back off
and we've got our depth map here
and
that's all we basically have to do okay
now in the past if i wanted to do this
effect
and if for any of you who have seen
beyond the pearlex effect i would
literally have to take a paint brush
and i would take my paintbrush from
black
to different shades of gray all the way
to white to actually paint this so i
would paint over the image and i would
create this depth map
with a paintbrush and
gray values
uh
black to white to get this depth map but
you don't have to do it anymore because
depth photoshop is smart enough with
this algorithm to figure out how to
create a depth map
so
i can click ok
and
what it's going to do is it's going to
it's going to do its thing again
and you're going to see here
that
i'm almost covering up the window or the
image but now there's two layers right
there's a background
layer which is our original image
and then there's a new layer one which
is our depth map okay
so that's all we need now we can jump
into after effects so i will save this
file i've already done that so i save it
as a
just a normal photoshop file okay but
jump back here into after effects
and
i am going to import
my file if i can move this out of the
way here
actually let's just cancel that i have
it pulled up right here
um so we've got our image our photoshop
file here and i'm going to drag this in
and it's really important that you drag
this in as a composition
retain layer sizes okay we don't want to
bring this in as one footage file we
want to be able to pull from both of
these layers
so composition retain layer styles okay
and there it is and if i double click it
it's going to open up a new
composition here
and again we see the same thing we see
layer 1 which is our depth map and we
see the original image here
okay
so next what we need to do is select our
image and we're going to go up to effect
and we're going to go to
distort
and we're going to go to displacement
map
and we're going to change our horizontal
displace
pull this out
from red to luminance and from green to
luminance
sometimes
changing these values from the color
channel to luminance makes a difference
sometimes it doesn't
but by default
this is what i do i change it to
luminance okay
next thing we'll do is we're going to
change the displacement map layer from
the original image to our layer 1 which
is our depth map
and boom it kind of changed something in
there in the image okay
and i have some settings here that i
pulled up ahead of time
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to these numbers default to five
and five so i'm just gonna
start playing around with this and you
can see
that i'm i'm able to create this
parallax movement by dragging the slider
this horizontal slider
um left and right right now it does
create some weird artifact and that
you're gonna see like back in here back
over here things like that if you push
this effect too far okay even like in
here we're seeing this okay but i'm
going to show you how to kind of get rid
of some of that
so
let's see we'll go to negative 70 here
and then we're going to
do the vertical movement here you can
see the same thing we get some crazy
vertical movement
but we don't want to push it too far
or it's going to look kind of funky
so let's set a keyframe for vertical
displacement and horizontal displacement
there
and then let's go to like five seconds
here hit n on the keyboard
to stop
uh the playback here
and if i hit u you're going to see we
have two keyframes at the beginning so
now what i like to do is i have to go
the opposite way so i went negative 70
and negative 175 to begin with
so
i'm going to go to my end values here
which were
looks like i went to about 45. again
it's all a matter of taste here right
even i can push it to 50 maybe we'll see
what happens here
and we're going to take this one to a
positive
100.
and you can see all of a sudden this
still image now has
um
movement in it right
which is pretty cool now we get some
artifacting so a way to get rid of some
of this artifact that we see here
is actually to blur our depth layer
so if i turn my depth layer back on
and let me check
my
settings here
if we go to
effect
blur and sharpen and i typically go with
a fast box blur for this kind of stuff
it really doesn't matter you could use a
gaussian blur repeat edge pixels
click that on and
i'm going to crank this up
to
a pretty high number like 100
okay so now it looks like just a big
blob right like it's like well what's
that going to do you kind of get rid of
like the grayscale values without and
width
you're going to see
we still get um
and it's really important here to go
back into our displacement map and
change it from source to effects and
masks okay so that's going to look at
what effects are on our depth layer
and it should get rid of this layer
right here
or this kind of
strange thing there and there you go
boom now there is some weird things
happening because we blurred like
there's this bending here on the left
there's some bending on the right
stuff that's stuff you definitely need
to be aware of
and you know i can adjust that i can
kind of take that down by dropping
the blur level to maybe 50
and i'm kind of just kind of i'm trying
to find a good balance between
uh having these weird artifacts on the
side here
maybe 65 you know what let's let's bump
back up to 100.
something else we can do here is we can
actually go to effect
color correction and we could apply like
a levels
let's actually apply that before the
blur
and let's just drag our gray values here
see if we can create a little bit more
contrast
i don't want to create too much
and i'll see that's with
and
without it looks like it's not really
doing a whole lot here
so we're going to leave that off and
back here on output this is our actual
1080p composition so i'm going to take
this pre-comp drop it in here
and
i'm looking at this and i'm seeing like
okay well some of the artifacting i was
seeing on the sides
doesn't really apply it so much here
because i'm cropped in
on what my audience is going to see
so that's key too i mean you're always
wanting to work with
areas of the image that you're actually
going to see right so if we have this
weird artifacting that's happening on
the sides but we're not actually going
to see the sides of the image then you
know why spend a ton of time trying to
fix that when we're never going to see
it so let's actually drop this down to
half res
and let's watch it play back here
and it's kind of going through its
motions
and there we go so again we started with
a you know just a flat photograph no
movement and
by applying this displacement map to it
we're getting some interesting movement
here within the image and again you can
go back in the displacement settings you
can tweak you know from from what point
it starts to what point it ends vice
versa and just kind of fine tune it to
get it where you want it to be
let me show you one more example
here so we'll jump back in here and i've
got another image here i like to use
this effect a lot with faces
um
it's really powerful with with like
headshots and faces and things like that
also with architecture as you just saw
so
we have a portrait that already has
depth of field
applied that was you know applied during
the actual photography process
we'll go to filter
neurofilters
let that load up
depth blur we're gonna go ahead and turn
that on
let it do its thing
and we're going to as soon as it applies
it
depth map only
and let's try focus subject let's see
so without focus subject
it's looking like there's a lot more
depth to it right so you can see focus
subjects on
um it's just like there's a lot of black
with a little bit of white in the
background
but to really bring this to life we're
going to want to do you know something
like with this when we see here work
with this so we're going to say okay
it's going to create a
layer like we see here we're going to
save this out which i've already done
jump back here in after effects
and here it is right here bring it into
after effects same thing composition
retain layer sizes
okay
and i'm going to double click
and kind of zoom out here
same thing we're going to take our
bottom layer and go to effect uh let's
see here distort
displacement map
and we're going to turn off our top
layer which is our displacement map
and we're going to change source
to effects and masks but we'll actually
we'll do that after we apply the blur
so we'll go from red to luminance green
to luminance we set a keyframe for
horizontal displacement and vertical
displacement
and let me look at my numbers looks like
i went like 80 and 60.
so let's pump this up to 80.
uh which you can see here right it looks
pretty funky right but we're going to
fix that with the blur
so maybe 60 and we'll go to the end here
and hit n
and negative 90 and negative 60. so
we'll go the opposite here negative 90.
that's good negative 60.
it's working here
and i mean like just off the top this
looks you know horrible right
but we can go to our our depth map and
we'll actually turn that one on
and we'll go to
blur and sharpen and we'll do fastbox
blur
and we'll repeat edge pixels
and this one we're going to crank way up
like maybe up in here
and then we're also going to apply
effect color correction
levels
and take that above the blur
and
maybe somewhere in here turn off that
depth layer
and then it's important that we go back
to our displacement map effect now and
change it from source
to
oh we gotta change this
there's part of the problem there change
it from source so back to layer one and
then effects and mask and we'll get rid
of all this weird edging here
boom
so now if i bring this one into my
comp and let's scale it down to maybe
maybe something like that
and you're going to see like with with
portraits like this
headshots it looks like
a lot of times by doing
um
the playing with the horizontal and the
vertical displacement it kind of looks
like it makes them look like they're
kind of turning their head and looking
up or looking down
which is pretty powerful
so you can see there looks like he's
he's turning his head
uh and that my friends is what i want to
show you today that is how you use
neural filters
with
images and after effects
so yeah i think it looks so cool just so
um to tell you guys a story i did a
memorial video for a relative of mine
a few years ago
five years ago
uh who had passed away and um
i took all these old photographs of them
or black and white photos and i did this
type of effect to them
and i mean
it just kind of blew everyone away
because it basically brings someone who
who is
deceased back to life and essentially uh
by putting movement into their
photographs
um
again back in that day
you know just five years ago four years
ago
we had to go in and we had to paint in
photoshop with black
and white values grayscale values
to create a depth map like this but now
with the neural filter
it's really easy to do
so i'm going to switch back over here
pull up some of my windows here so i can
see some things
and
yeah awesome just reading through your
comments so um hey zach great to have
you here
um let me know if you guys have any
questions about
this process
as i said it's very straightforward
it's just something i came across a few
weeks ago that i didn't even know was
you know existed in neurofilters
because i don't spend a lot of time in
photoshop these days to be honest
any of you who take any of my courses
will know that most of my designing
95 of it is typically all in after
effects
so
you know just like i don't spend a lot
of time in photoshop and when i do it's
just like kind of it's fun to go back
and see what's there and and what the
possibilities are
so
um
yeah and and blacksmooths said uh
alexander said add the puppet pin and
the puppet pin also helps it does again
that's some stuff that's a little bit
deeper
uh like in parallaxing but you can
use the puppet pin with like people's
arms and legs and things like that
to
you know get them to move additionally
an example of like the the old man that
i just worked on
something we could do with that is add
the puppet pen to the mouth and kind of
make him smile a little bit which is
kind of fun
um but uh yeah
neurofilters like cuts down time so
um all right so you guys don't look like
you don't have any questions for me
today so i'm gonna wrap this one up it's
a shorter one today but uh i did enjoy
it
i do wanna remind you free five day
challenge if you want a career in motion
graphics
uh definitely check out this challenge
that starts monday january 31st and it
goes through friday
five days five days of live teaching
from me
uh and live q a we're going to go about
an hour each day if you can't make it
it's at 1 pm eastern time if you can't
make it
the videos are recorded and you can
always go back and see them but the only
way to see them is to actually um
signed up for the challenge it's not
going to be made public here on youtube
or anything like that so i hope to see
you guys there
um
and i got a quick question here from
goodtimes lawrence
why does starcraft now require
registration is it part of a future
announcement ah good question
[Music]
there's a lot of different reasons
behind it lauren a lot of different
reasons uh back in the day stylecraft uh
used to be open and closed and we'd
bring in a group at a time
uh and there was a reason for that and
we're going back to that so uh people
who want to join starcraft have to wait
you have to register get on the waitlist
if you want to be in it it's going to be
more exclusive
uh versus keeping up open all the time
so
that is why thanks for the question
laurent um okay
so
thanks everyone for being here today and
i just want to wrap with this uh the
best way to get better at motion
graphics is to keep creating and
practicing
you can watch other people's work you
can learn from it and you can find ways
that you can improve upon it
you need to stay motivated you need to
experiment with new techniques
and above all above all else have fun
with your work that is so key
with enough practice you'll become a
master of the craft and produce stunning
visuals that could capture people's
attention
thanks for being here today everyone
i'm cameron and
this is motion science
you